benvenuti alla seconda stagione del
leccio con karim usa come potete vedere
sono riuscito a non far fallire una
serie bravo on me e come vi avevo
promesso da questo momento in avanti
ogni singolo video sarà del leisure
compreso pausa che porca miseria ve lo
giuro mi era mancato farlo e come avete
potuto vedere dal titolo voglio iniziare
con pokémon
ebbene sì l'intera saga di pokémon io
devo dire di averla seguita
relativamente poco per esempio dei
videogiochi o soltanto giocato è finito
la prima serie quello di pokemon rosso e
poche mondo poi ho giocato un discreto
numero di tempo al gioco di carter
mentre la serie animata io l'ho sempre
trovata molto infantile
ogni volta che era in tv la guardavo ma
non con la giusta attenzione ho sempre
dato priorità ad altri cartoni animali
non saprei neanche di b realmente il
perché ma una cosa è certa non ho mai
visto il primo episodio e le regole di
pausa non si toccano mi sono informato
il meno possibile in modo da rendere
l'impatto di questa visione della prima
puntata assolutamente autentico dunque
perché pokémon beh ultimamente con
alcuni amici ci siamo voluti rivedere i
film dei pokémon
beh diciamo che è stata un'esperienza
magica
questo è un pc o l'oggetto e abbiamo
notato che i film sono invecchiati
maluccio lo so lo so che tra alcuni di
voi ci saranno i più grandi appassionati
di questi film della serie sicuramente
va benissimo tutto però per quanto
riguarda noi durante la visione
diciamo che ci siamo abbastanza rotti i
[ __ ]
ma basta perdere tempo e guardiamo
insieme il primo episodio di pokémon e
questo è sempre vuota inutile che ci
propone altro
ma questo inizio e spettacolare cazzo
perché fa le due cose fondamentali per
catturare l'attenzione dei fan di
pokémon punto uno ti fa capire da subito
che sì questa è una serie tratta dal
videogioco come facendo di vedere la
transizione da videogioco a serie punto
2 non perde tempo non ci sono quelle
lunghe e noiose presentazioni dei
personaggi devono raccontare la
cronostoria quanti penny nel culo anno
no pokémon è un videogioco dove ci sono
animali che se menano facciamo vedere
animali che sebbene non ammazza se la
puntata è tutta così siamo a cavallo
dicevo come avete potuto sentire lui e
ash anche se noi gli ha chiesto nessuno
lui da solo i camera ha voluto dircelo è
ora che ho compiuto dieci anni fa tra
diventare allenatore di boxe non ho
capito quanti anni e ora che ho compiuto
10 anni lo madonna va bene quindi mi
stai dicendo che se non fossero esistiti
youtuber tutti i bambini di 10 anni
sarebbero diventati allenatori di
pokémon è certo perché se non si fosse
capito dalle miliardi e miliardi di
oggetti a tema pokémon che a questo
ragazzino dentro camera sua
lui vorrebbe diventare un allenatore può
che monti il mio grande sogno è di poter
dichiarare un giorno a tutto il mondo
sono diventata una estra di pokémon
guarda per me puoi diventare quello che
vuoi avrei giusto una piccolissima
domanda con chi cazzo stai parlando da
solo in camera tua questa diventerà
sfila letto
sono le undici dovresti essere già a
dormire ma quello era un volto con
dentro un pg a cucù e perché è così la
madre di asce lo manda a letto perché
lui l'indomani dovrà scegliere uno dei
tre starter o guarda che carino che va a
dormire con la coperta con le sfere
poche disegnati sopra ma basta abbiamo
capito ma questo è un incubo
mamma mia se avessi un dubbio che mi fa
questo sono nelle orecchie ogni mattina
per svegliarmi numeri già strozzato mai
nude tre volte quelli che se ne intende
lo dicono che sia il miglior germain der
e il collo proprio una camicia coi baffi
ma per errore tira la sveglia contro il
muro e si alza tardi arrivato appunto
ritardo sbatte per la prima volta contro
ieri
meglio tardi che mai signorina lei
signor carey per te mostra un poco di
rispetto a ieri mi ha incontrati un
sacco di ragazzi come quel bonaccione
figlio di papà che nonostante la sua
arguta intelligenza riesca a sfruttarla
nel modo peggiore possibile
se lo lasci dire lei signor gary è un
pezzo di merda grazie ragazzi grazie
ho capito ma io che ho fatto il milione
di iscritti su youtube non ce l'ho le
cheerleaders devo rimediare
presentandoti in tempo avresti visto che
il professor o che mi ha dato il miglior
pokémon che c'era del resto è utile
avere un nonno nel mondo del pokémon non
trovi ed eccolo qua il raccomandato dal
nonno bravo dell'esempio e per colpa di
gente come te che paletta une bella ma
non ci vivrei e mentre il pubblico se ne
va con delle transizioni di movie maker
ashe è pronto più che mai per prendere
il suo primo pokémon e incontriamo per
la prima volta il professor hoc ma
vorrei seguire il corso in pigiama
professore sono pronto per addestrare un
po che non va bene ma stai tranquillo
ash ma alla fine ho scelto scritto e
questo l'hanno preso abeti rimangono
comunque bull basauri charming allora
sceglierà come mio pokémon bull basauri
ok vada la butto lì e mi sa che neanche
charm and her c'è una cosa
professore perché cazzo lei è rimasto lì
a fissarlo aprire tutte e tre le poche
vuole fargli vedere che non c'era niente
dentro non poteva dirglielo subito così
ci risparmiavamo st scena pietosa e no
perché lei è dovuto rimanere sadicamente
a guardarlo aprile le sfere vuote e
godere nel veder è il cuore del povero a
spaccarsi in mille pezzi ad ogni singola
sfera vuota ma lei non è un professore
lei è un romanzo di edgar allan poe
fatta persona
paura perché ma fortuna vuole che c'è
ancora un pokémon per acer un pokémon
contenuto in una poké ball che esce da
un meccanismo all'interno del tavolo ma
che è sta roba minority report blade
runner due son finiti e comunque glielo
poteva dire prima
non vi preoccupate non è la vostra
connessione scrausa 7 mega telecom
ma è proprio la puntata ad andare a
circa 23 frame al secondo
e finalmente l'incontro più famoso dei
cartoni animati ash vede per la prima
volta un pikachu curvi ma quindi nel
mondo dei pokémon la concezione del
collo non esiste ma questo pikachu non è
così affettuoso come sembra città sono
abbastanza convinto che ci sia gente che
è morta per molti meno vault di quelli
che sono i tuoi fini da una volta di
colture una personalità ed è frizzante
no non lo dirà non lo può dire un
professore cia gli attestati ai
riconoscimenti ci alle lauree non si può
abbassare a questi livelli non lo fanno
loro dice capisco a cosa intende
e scioccante vero boom è stato bello dai
spegniamo le luci grazie mille ciao
grazie a 6 sfere potere è però sto
fugace non scorso mamma mia
e mentre ghedi aveva delle vere e propri
gruppi che risultavano per lui e molto
probabilmente gli avrebbero anche
regalato nel sesso orale esce chi ha la
madre mamma mia che vita e mentre la
madre si asciuga il moccolo sullo zaino
che sta per dare ad ash e fu così che
l'intero villaggio di palle town fu
ucciso da un pino
uomini gomma di tua madre ti saranno
utili fermati mite se questo poveraccio
soltanto perché si è svegliato
leggermente più tardi degli altri deve
usare dei guanti di gomma rosa della
madre con cui lava i piatti per poter
tenere questo pikachu incontrollabile
pikachu ha intenzione di fare così per
tutto il viaggio è il primo pokémon che
trovano asce pixum camminando per strada
e un pgt g come pokémon gol e lui invece
di combattersi contro gli tira
direttamente la sfera poche e ovviamente
pg scappa e quindi dopo che il pokédex
apertamente detto per catturare un
pokémon è necessario per combattere con
quello che si desidera prendere adesso
me lo dici cosa farà mai il nostro usher
ovvio prende la maglietta del suo
pigiama sporco e tenta di soffocare pg
ovviamente pg che nonostante sia una
specie di piccione comunque più
intelligente di ash debutta prima un
tornado e poi la tempesta di sabbia
addosso ma volendo anche l'avvocato il
professore lo youtube e poi ci sono
mille cose che puoi fare ash e che per
forza ti devi puntare con allenatori di
pokémon se non riesce lo riesci ma nel
frattempo appare il secondo pokemon che
incontrano per strada
esattamente come pokemon go
ma quando poi lontananza paiono 3 p g
nonostante il pokédex li abbia detto
guarda che devi far combattere in un tuo
pokémon contro quell'altro e cosa fai un
genio mancato lo sai
sono i bambini come te quelli senza
controllo senza un supervisore avuto che
gli sta dietro che stanno distruggendo
la community italiana di youtube quelli
che non hanno nessuna regola quelli che
tirano le pietre ai pg per strada quelli
che ne soffocano con una maglietta
perché tanto non hanno nessuno che gli
prende a schiaffi quelli che appunto
stanno su internet anche se l'età minima
non è quella giusta perché tanto nessuno
ti dice niente e quindi iniziano a
guardare i video di merda ea iscriversi
a commentare i video di verde quindi
questi video vanno continuamente nelle
tendenze di youtube italia e noi per
colpa vostra per colpa della vostra
mancata supervisione degli adulti ci
dobbiamo peccare giorno dopo giorno sti
cazzo di video di merda sti cazzo di
canali di probabilità e non importa non
ti preoccupare
e intanto quel teppistello di asti a
un'altra pietra bravo e questa volta
bank a qualcuno ma non è un pg e uno
spiro
quello che mi sembra un pc che a sto
giro attacca anche pikachu lascia stare
dica ciò non è stata la grande sas ma
non è solo un intero esercito di spiro e
all'attacco dei due protagonisti e sai
una cosa
ti sta bene pikachu però viene ferito
gravemente e us con tutta l'adrenalina
che ha in corpo riesce a districarsi tra
gli spyro ea prenderlo in braccio
e non solo per scappare si butta anche
giù da una scogliera
ed è qui che incontriamo per la prima
volta misti che letteralmente lo pesca e
come se non bastasse si prende un
cazziatone anche da lei guarda che hai
fatto a questa povera creatura te lo
starter e visse dovuto ma non vedi che
ha bisogno di un dottore
ok ricapitolando questo spacca la
sveglia si sveglia in ritardo si becca
gli insulti da ieri e dal professor hoc
non trova più nessun pokémon ed è
costretto a prendere un pikachu che non
è simpatico non riesce a catturare
nessun pgm su retata viene attaccato da
uno stormo di spiro un precipita da 200
metri d'altezza e viene salvato da misti
che comunque gli fa il cazziatone
guardano non moltissimo ma scommetto 5
euro che cade dalla bici
grazie ma pikachu finalmente decide di
fare qualcosa e salva la situazione a 10
frame al secondo
e vissero tutti felici e oh mio dio è
morto e in cielo intanto passa o o ma mi
ricordo male o quel po che moglie e
della seconda generazione
prima di tutto spoiler non è ancora i
denti ma come ma tu non sei un
enciclopedia cosa vuol dire che non sai
cos'è e la puntata finisce così con asce
che tiene in braccio un pikachu senza
vita e cerca di andare nella città più
vicina per curarlo noi scopriremo una
magia ai misteri di un mondo
meraviglioso
quindi questa era il primo episodio di
pokémon e sai cosa devo dire che mi è
piaciuto molto più del previsto
è un po bambinesco di certo il target
non è fatto di ragazzi di 27 anni però
sai cosa ha molto cuore nel senso che
avrebbero potuto semplicemente far
funzionare fin da subito il rapporto tra
pikachu e ash invece avuto costruirlo
sulle difficoltà il dover sopravvivere
insieme a delle situazioni difficili e
che per un cartone fatto per bambini non
è da poco
e dunque abbiamo finalmente iniziato
ufficialmente la seconda stagione dello
show probabilmente avrete visto che il
mio avatar è cambiato il nome ho deciso
di lasciarlo così perché è meglio così
per il resto
grazie mille e ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video
questo è un piccolo